[Música]
desde chamo escuche siempre el tema de
que somos creativos de qué
todas las situaciones que se nos
plantean las podemos resolver porque
somos seres creativos
pero resulta que quería compartir con
ustedes este pequeño descubrimiento
una idea que surgió además a raíz de la
experiencia
y aunque es tema de los seres creativos
reales
descubrí que los seres humanos no son
creativos para nada al contrario existe
un planeta que está ubicado entre el
planeta tierra entre la corteza verdad
entre la superficie el planeta tierra lo
que conocemos todos como esos y la
atmósfera exterior lo que nos conecta
con el universo exterior existe otro
planeta un planeta que no vemos aquí en
este planeta viven unos seres que se
llaman los seres creativos son unos
personajes distintos a los que estamos
acostumbrados no tienen no tienen la
forma ni el sabor ni el color de lo que
ya estamos más o menos acostumbrados ni
en el sonido son unos personajes
totalmente distintos y necesito que
hagan el esfuerzo de no escucharme a mí
sino de imaginarse por un momento cómo
es ese planeta que está entre la
superficie del planeta tierra y la
atmósfera que nos une con el mundo
exterior imagínense ese lugar que no es
un lugar cualquiera es un lugar
es como el planeta tierra solo que están
más arriba tiene ciudades tiene árboles
tiene personajes que caminan solamente
que no se parece a nosotros y son los
verdaderos seres creativos
hables de la creatividad del hombre y
eso lo interesante la primera evidencia
de esto lo encontramos más o menos hace
como 15 mil años cuando el hombre de las
cavernas por primera vez conoció a un
ser creativo y estableció un vínculo y
una relación con ellos
y nació una relación de amor que se
mantiene está hoy día en una relación de
amor que empezó a producir este tipo de
cosas ok empezó a producir experiencias
creativas entonces es esta relación que
nace este vínculo que se crea en tiempos
remotos se desarrolla poco a poco en la
historia y empezamos a ver como algunos
personajes muy locos establecen esa
relación con los seres creativos crean
esa especie de matrimonio con un ser
creativo y desarrollan su potencialidad
y empiezan a producir este tipo de obras
hermosísimas y son evidencias de esa
relación entre el hombre y los seres
creativos pero más adelante vemos desde
hecho casos como éste otros tipos donde
son más promiscuos de relación con más
de un ser creativo por ejemplo este tipo
se empató como con diez seres creativos
y lograron hacer esta obra inmensa la
maravilla
elsa lo interesante de esta experiencia
de los seres creativos con los hombres
pero la cosa siguió avanzando así como
avanzó la historia de la humanidad
avanzó la historia de los seres
creativos en paralelo llegó la era
industrial las cosas empezaron a
comercializarse los seres creativos se
comenzaron a interesar en el tema
comercial nació la publicidad se llenó
todo de imagen en el mundo se aceleró
vamos al millón pero descuidamos tal vez
en ese en este tiempo moderno
violentísimo estamos tal vez descuidando
ese vínculo que nos une con nuestros
seres creativos que viven en ese planeta
intermedio entre la tierra y el espacio
exterior y eso es lo que deberíamos
reflexionar en este caso
no debemos perder la conexión con los
seres creativos porque
porque estos tiempos acelerados nos
hacen distraernos y la relación con los
seres creativos una relación amorosa
apasionada y solamente con amor y
compasión podemos crear esa relación ese
vínculo con unos seres creativos una
idea cuando estamos cuando tenemos una
situación difícil de afrontar una
situación difícil y tenemos que
resolverla cuando tenemos que buscar una
solución creativa
y de repente no damos con la solución
nos sentimos como solos como
desamparados cierto pero hay un momento
creativo que todos hemos vivido alguna
vez donde decimos que la solución va por
aquí y le damos la vuelta al tema y
descubrimos la solución y sentimos como
maripositas en el estómago algunos
siente como un sudor frío aquí en la
parte de atrás esos son los momentos
creativos cuando estamos vinculados con
esos seres que viven en ese planeta
intermedio es una evidencia más de que
existe en estos seres creativos
la relación con los seres creativos
debemos cultivarlas en este caso tenemos
que hacerle caso óscar tenemos que
cultivar la compasión tenemos que
aportarle a esa relación como en un
matrimonio tenemos que aportarle
muchísimo amor cuando cuando nos
vinculamos con un ser creativo
tenemos que que como cualquier relación
tenemos que estar pendientes
concentrarnos dedicarnos a la relación
sacarla llevarla al cine comprar el ramo
de flores porque es lo importante para
ser creativo es estrecharse cada vez más
con este ser creativo que que podemos
encontrar
y alimentar esa relación entonces como
en un matrimonio por ejemplo cuando
cuando dejamos que las cosas se
conviertan en cotidianidad cuando nos
conformamos cuando aceptamos la
situación es tal cual vienen las la cosa
pierde pierde el calor pierde pierde
fuerza en cambio cuando le imprimimos
amor a una relación y comienzan a
aparecer las soluciones creativas ok y
eso lo que necesitamos aportarle a una
relación con los seres creativos tenemos
que
y darle reducir al ser creativo para que
las ideas creativas bajen hasta nosotros
tenemos que convencerlo tenemos que
enamorar los días días tenemos que
imprimir la pasión a los problemas para
encontrar las soluciones
y gracias a oscar por los consejos son
excelentes
el tema es donde establecemos buenas
conexiones con los seres creativos hay
gente que la hace en las carreteras
viajando de noche cuando van solos por
ahí se le empiezan a ocurrir grandes
ideas vienen los seres y se incorporan y
empiezan a producir grandes ideas hay
personas que se inspiran con un
atardecer hay personas que lo hacen en
la bañera cuando se están bañando y hay
muchísima gente que utiliza esta silla
moderna para conectarse con los seres
creativos y la cosa realmente funciona
yo quiero dedicarle este tema a un pana
pana de todos además que se vinculó con
estos seres creativos conoció muy de
cerca este mundo y le interesó tanto que
se fue un rato para allá
a explorar un poco la cosa un poco más
la cosa y que estoy seguro que va a
estar pronto otra vez con nosotros
dedico esto al amigo gustavo cerati
gracias
[Música]
faltan
no quiso despertar quería no sólo al mar